[Musique]
tous
j'ai commencé la culture j'avais 19 ans
donc eu 18 ans même j'étais un peu en
échec scolaire
et puis j'ai fait un bep métiers de la
mode à orléans et c'est ça qui a été
vraiment une révélation pour moi ce qui
me plaît dans chapeau plus dans
l'accessoire que dans le vêtement c'est
que on est plus libre j'ai l'impression
il n'y a pas tellement de règles et puis
c'est presque de la sculpture en fait
c'est un peu un peu faire tout ce qu'on
veut on peut utiliser plein de matières
différentes c'est moins rigide que le
que le vêtement
ça paraît simple comme ça quand j'ai
commencé je quand on voit les anciennes
faire et puis finalement content pour la
boule dans la main là c'est une autre
histoire faut vraiment passer comme tous
les métiers artisanaux il faut il faut
il faut s'entraîner quoi
je trouve que la fleur c'est vraiment
technique quoi si on n'a jamais fait le
geste à acquérir il est vraiment
compliqué quoi alors que le chapeau on
peut hein peut s'improviser modiste
[Musique]
chaque pétale et formé à la main et
collet est monté à la main quoi je
défends vraiment ça le travail de
l'artisan le geste essayer d'adopter
mire le geste parfait c'est des métiers
qui sont qui aujourd'hui sont inconnues
il faut les faire connaître et les
transmettre aux plus jeunes
[Musique]